The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So
today, what we want
to do is we want to talk
about two related topics.
The first is going
to this question
of the evolution of
virulence and how
to model host-parasite
interactions more broadly.
That's kind of modeled on
chapter 11 of Martin's book.
We'll focus on the first half
of it for the discussions today.
This is in the context of
when a given host can only
have one strain of the
parasite or virus or whatnot
inside that body.
The model presented
in Martin's book
is very similar to classic
models in epidemiology, which
are the so-called
SIR type models,
where you divide up
the host population
into whether the they
are sensitive-- i.e.,
non-infected--
infected, or resistant.
And then, we'll
draw the parallels
of how we get from the model
that you read about in Martin's
book to the classic SIR models.
But in both of these cases,
the fundamental parameter
that drives these things
is this R0 parameter.
It tells us about the
expected number of new cases
that will result when you
introduce one infected member
into the population.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, will you be
taking about super-infections?
PROFESSOR: Only a
little bit but, I
would say, depending on time.
But if you're interested in
the super-infection discussion
more, we can talk about
it after class, maybe.
All right.
And so, for the
second half of class,
what we're going to
do though is we're
going to talk about the possible
evolutionary benefits of sex.
And in particular, we'll talk
about this hypothesis, which
is one of the reigning
hypotheses for why it might
be that sex is as widespread as
it is, which is the Red Queen
hypothesis, from
Lewis Carroll's novel.
And we're going to discuss this
paper that you guys read about,
"Running with the
Red Queen," which
I think has a nice
discussion of this debate
and, then, some nice
experiments looking
at experimental coevolution
between the C. elegans worm
and it's infecting parasite,
which is a serratia bacterium.
Any questions
before we get going?
OK, what I want to do
is start by discussing
this model in Martin's book.
But also, there's a little bit
of this philosophical question.
Any time, that you are
modeling, you always
had to make decisions
about which of the details
you want to try to model
and which of the details
you do not want to model.
And depending upon
the situation,
it may be that some
assumptions are more or less
appropriate than others.
Now, in the model that
Martin wrote down-- well,
we'll try to figure out what
the assumptions are here.
So we have what
you might think of
as some sensitive individuals.
Plus, the infected
individuals are going
to interact at some rate, beta.
So this is how the
sensitive become infected.
And it results in, now,
two infected individuals.
Now of course, each
of these individuals
will, say, have some
lifespan or die at some rate.
All right, so the sensitive
or uninfected individuals
die at rate u.
Whereas, infected individuals,
others-- an increase
in the death-rate, described
by some virulence, v. OK?
OK.
Now, the model as
written-- what's
going to be the fate
of the population?
AUDIENCE: Everyone all dies.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Everyone's going to die, right?
And that's even true
in the-- it's not
even that the population's dying
as a result of the infection.
Because even in the absence
of any infected individuals,
you just have people dying.
So you need to have some way of
keeping the population going,
so you can study it perhaps.
What we're going to assume is
that sensitive individuals,
or uninfected individuals,
will enter the population just
at some rate, k.
Now, in terms of the
philosophical question,
in the beginning of
the chapter, Martin
talks a bit about this
question of microparasites
versus macroparasites.
And I can somebody remind
us, what's the distinction?
and For what kind of
parasite might this
be intended to model?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Well, what I got
from it is that microparasites
are on the order of
single-cellular organisms,
generally things that have much
shorter reproductive steps,
I guess.
They reproduce a
lot more frequently.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
AUDIENCE: Whereas,
macro-parasites
are like the [INAUDIBLE] or
the tapeworm or something,
which would not
necessarily reproduce
a lot inside the host.
PROFESSOR: Mm-hm.
Right.
And I would say, that just
given this distinction
between the microparasites, that
might be viruses and bacteria,
as compared to the
macroparasites,
that are things like
tapeworms and so forth, it's
not obvious from that
that you would have two
different modeling frameworks.
But what is the argument that
is made in Martin's book?
Or can you think up
an argument for why
it is that it might be this
kind of model you would
want to use for microparasites?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Because
we don't really
care about-- he
mentioned something
that the microparasites
reproduce
in large numbers in
infected individuals.
So we don't have to keep
track of the internal state
of someone that's infected.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
And some of it's, maybe,
even a historical thing.
There might be huge numbers of
viruses-- a flu virus or so--
in an infected individual.
And in some ways,
maybe, the number
of viruses that is in that host
is not the most relevant thing.
And it's certainly
would be much more
complicated to try to
keep track of that.
And so, if you can get
meaningful predictions-- rather
than keeping track of the number
of viruses, say, in each host,
instead you just put the
host into different classes--
sensitive and
infected, for example.
Later, we'll talk about
what happens if you
have a resistant type of class.
But the idea there is that
there's, maybe, even also
some separation of time scales.
Because you get infected.
And kind of quickly, you're
just sick and may be infective.
But at some rate,
you get better.
And it's not that
you'll necessarily
gain very much by keeping
track of the precise number
of viruses in the host.
Of course, this is ultimately
an experimental observational
question of whether
this sort of model
provides you inside
that you're going
to need to make sense of
these diseases, right?
AUDIENCE: And then it also
seems like your method
of transmission
of macroparasites
can be very different.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So the mechanism of
transmission depends
very much on the disease
that you're studying.
And the macroparasites,
in many cases,
they're transmitted not
from direct interactions
between the hosts, but through
the environment or something
else.
It's also, perhaps,
just worth pointing out
that parasites are just a
ubiquitous aspect of life.
So you can name an organism,
and you can pretty much
be guaranteed that there's
going to be some notion
of a parasite on that organism.
And there can be
multiple layers of this.
So we certainly
have many parasites.
We're infected by many viruses
and bacteria and other things.
But bacteria-- we think of
them as being very small--
they're also preyed upon
by these phage, which
is a parasite that targets
specifically bacteria.
So it's not just that
it's an incidental thing.
But these are really viruses
that have evolved specifically
to divide in bacteria.
And we didn't really talk
about this very much.
But one of the classic models
for cooperation and cheating
is based on what you
could think about as
some sort of parasitic
sub-population within phage.
So this is a classic
paper by Lin Chow where
he showed that if you
evolved phage and bacteria
in a condition where many phage
infect a given bacteria, then,
you can evolve what you
could think of as cheater
strategies or cheater phage.
Because these are
phage that maybe
can't reproduce on their
own, but have shorter genomes
and can out-replicate
the normal phage.
So if both of these end up
in a single bacterial cell,
then these cheater
phage can spread
by taking advantage of, say,
the replication machinery
from the rest of the phage.
So in some ways, you might
call that some sort of DNA
parasite or so.
So there's really parasites in
many, many different levels.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ultimately think about is, k,
is this really the number--
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
you know, I would
say that the k is, in some ways,
not a very satisfying feature
of this model.
Because it makes it feel that
the model is very special,
right?
AUDIENCE: But I mean,
in a natural population
and rate at which people are
born, is that the same change?
Or--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
That was the example
I was going to give.
It's not clear-- of course,
it requires somebody
to give birth to kids, right?
So in that sense, modeling this
as a constant number per unit
of time-- which is what
we're doing-- this rate k,
is a little bit funny.
Because then, what
you'd really want to do
is say, oh, maybe
it's these guys that
give birth at some rate
or so, if you really
wanted to be accurate.
So I'd say that this
is, in some ways, just
a mathematical simplification
so that we can get
at the heart of the dynamics.
And what we'll see is
that, in these SIR models,
you don't invoke
anything like this.
But rather, what you do is
you assume that, at some rate,
infected individuals
don't just die.
But they become resistant.
And then, maybe later, they
become sensitive again.
So you need some way of
being sure that it's not
the case that everybody
just always dies.
So in some ways, this is more
mathematical convenience.
And the basic
conclusions end up being
very robust to these
sorts of things.
All right, so in
these models, it's
always good to be
clear about how
we go from this framework
to something that is more
of a differential equation.
And what we can
do is we can think
about these uninfected
individuals, i.e.
the S-es as compared
to the infected.
And we're going to
have these guys be x.
And this S and I.
So the way that the
x will be changing
is that we're assuming
that there's always
some influx of
individuals, which
could be birth or migration
or something else,
that are just always entering.
But then, there's
going to be two ways
that x is going to decrease.
One is that there's just a
death rate that is resulting
in the absence of infection.
But then, also,
there's going to be
some rate of infection,
which is going
to be proportional to beta.
So this is the
simplest way that you
can imagine capturing
this element
that the infected individuals
can transmit the infection
to the sensitive individuals.
So we're modeling them as
a well-mixed population,
just like in chemical reactions.
And somehow, the
rate of infection
is proportional to the frequency
that they hit each other.
Certainly, the simplest kind
of model you can imagine.
Whereas, the infected
individuals-- well,
we're going to have an
increased rate of death.
So this is a simplified
way to write it.
So this is really that there's
a minus, u plus v times y.
So this is just the death rate.
But then, any individual that
leaves the sensitive class--
this minus beta xy--
enters the infected class.
This makes a lot
of sense, I think.
Now, the question is, can we
make sense of what's going on?
Now, you saw in your reading
what this R0 parameter was.
And you should always
remember that it's
defined as this thing
of, if you introduce
one infected individual
into a population
of sensitive
individuals, what is
the mean number of new
infections that you get?
And it makes sense that the
key thing is whether that R0
is greater or less than 1.
Because if it's
greater than one,
that leads to this
exponential explosion
of the infected individuals.
It doesn't mean that everyone's
going to die, necessarily.
We'll get into that.
But if R0 is less
than 1, then you
expect that
infection to die out.
So why is it that if
R0 is greater than 1,
and you introduce one
infected individual,
it doesn't necessarily
lead to a wipe-out
of the entire population?
Or maybe it does.
This model is a little funny.
Because you always have
an individual entering.
But--
AUDIENCE: If the [INAUDIBLE]
is really virulent,
then only infected
individuals die before--
PROFESSOR: Right.
So if it's very virulent,
then the infected individuals
may die quickly.
And this gets into
this question of there
may be some trade-offs
in terms of virulence.
And we'll talk more about, then,
the evolution of virulence.
But there's a wide variety
of classes of models,
not just the ones where
you have k entering.
But the question somehow
is-- just because R0
is greater than 1,
that doesn't mean
that the entire population will
necessarily become infected.
Because we have this idea
of an exponential growth
of the infected population
if R0 is greater than 1.
So why is it that
it's not necessarily
going to happen that the
entire population is-- well,
this question's a little
bit ill-posed in this model.
AUDIENCE: Is it because the
number of sensitive individuals
becomes very low
at some point and--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
And I think this is
the basic intuition.
As more and more members of
the population become infected,
then that could, in
principle, reduce
to the possibilities for new
individuals to be susceptible.
And I'm using susceptible and
sensitive interchangeably.
And so eventually,
this exponential growth
of the population can
be limited in some way.
We'll maybe look at
this a little bit more
in this SIR model.
Because it's more clear.
AUDIENCE: So we
basically collect a rate.
R0 is a rate, right?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No.
It's a number.
It's the expected
number of new infections
that you get when you introduce
one infected individual
into the population.
And we're--
AUDIENCE: It's like, period.
So there's not, like,
per-unit time or--
PROFESSOR: It's
a number, period.
AUDIENCE: OK, so if
you have R equal to 1,
you expect that
when you introduce
an infected individual
into a population
of sensitive individuals, you
will get one other infected
individual.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So that's kind of the
neutrally-stable situation.
If R0 is 1, then you add
one infected individual
and you expect to get one other
one, so you have a random walk
and-- well, in general,
it will randomly
go extinct, eventually.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What is the
lifetime of the infected--
PROFESSOR: So it depends.
And so, that's what we're
going to do right now
is see if we can reconstruct
what this R0 is equal to
in this model.
AUDIENCE: Another
quick question--
what's the distribution
of the-- so--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --a
deterministic role--
PROFESSOR: Yes, exactly.
So this is very interesting.
The question is, what is
going to the distribution
of the number of
infected individuals?
And in this model,
we're assuming
that every infected
individuals is the same.
So we should be able
to-- I wish that we
just, on the wall somewhere,
had our five different standard
probability distributions,
so that we could always
go back to them.
So the question
is, in this model,
if you introduce one infected
individual in the population,
how many new infected
individuals do you get?
R0 tells you about the mean.
But will you always
get the mean?
No.
So let's all think about
this for 10 seconds.
And we will verbally
yell out what
we think the
distribution will be
of the number of new infections
from a single infected
individual.
OK?
Verbally, ready!
Five, (WHISPERING) four--
AUDIENCE: Poisson.
AUDIENCE: Piosson.
AUDIENCE: Exponential
PROFESSOR: All right,
everybody thinks it's Poisson.
Why would it be Poisson?
AUDIENCE: Because
you have a rate--
AUDIENCE: It's not a rate.
AUDIENCE: It's not?
AUDIENCE: The initial
population is much larger--
PROFESSOR: Right.
OK, so the idea
is that we imagine
we're some infected individual.
And there's some rate that
we are infecting others.
Now, if I ask you the question,
how many individuals will I
infect in the next 10 days?
Or we could do 21 days
if you guys like that.
So all right, if I
ask, how many do I
infect in the next 10 days?
Now, I'm assuming
that I stay alive.
But let's say,
assuming I stay alive,
how many do I infect
over the next 10 days?
That's going to be distributed
as-- that is Poisson.
But the question you're
asking is a different one.
You're asking,
what is going to be
the distribution of the total
number of new infections
that I cause?
And this is precisely
the same situation
that we've analyzed
lots and lots of times.
What does it look like?
AUDIENCE: Geometric
distribution.
PROFESSOR: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: Geometric.
PROFESSOR: OK, yes.
It's going to be a
geometric distribution.
But why?
AUDIENCE: Well, because you
can have an infection and then
another infection.
And so then, it's,
like, multiples of ten.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So we have an
infected individual.
There's two things
that can happen.
He's going to die at some rate.
And there's this
other rate, which
is going to go as
beta times x or so,
telling us about the
rate of new infections.
And we want to know,
how many times do we
go around this loop before we
degrade, or die, or something,
disappear from the population?
Does this look at all familiar?
AUDIENCE: Mm-hmm.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Were you guys the
same students that
were here for the first
half of the class?
AUDIENCE: Ha.
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
No.
AUDIENCE: And so, R0 is
like the [INAUDIBLE]?
It's like the number of--
AUDIENCE: It's the
mean number for bursts.
AUDIENCE: You haven't
evaluated when the population--
PROFESSOR: So R0 is the
mean size of protein bursts,
in the context of this
other model, which
was-- what was the situation?
And this one's a really good
one for you guys to know.
It's going to be useful.
So we saw this exact model in
the context of gene expression.
And what was the
situation that we--
AUDIENCE: Production
of [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Production of--
AUDIENCE: --proteins
from a single mRNA.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the production
of proteins from a single mRNA.
Right?
Because remember, we had this
thing where we had the mRNA.
And we said, oh, well
the mRNA is going
to be degraded at some rate.
But also, it's going to be
translated at some rate.
So the distribution
number of times
that it's translated
before it degrades
is going to be geometric.
Because we go around this
loop some number of times.
All right, so this
is the same thing.
And the paper that I put
as supplementary reading,
by Jamie Lloyd-Smith?
I always get his name and
Jamie Lloyd Wright-- right?
Something-- mixed up.
But yeah, Jamie Lloyd-Smith.
Smith.
So he was studying the
dynamics of infections
when you have this
thing where there's
intrinsic variation in, say, the
infectivity of an individual.
Because here, you get this
geometric distribution,
even though all the individuals
are, in principal, identical.
Now, the question is, if there's
some distributions of, say,
infectivities, then
you'll get an even broader
distribution of resulting
number of new infections.
So there's this classic
thing of Typhoid Mary.
She's was a nurse-- OK, now
I don't remember the story.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: She was a cook.
PROFESSOR: A cook.
Oh, a cook, nurse--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] so she
cooked for a lot of people.
PROFESSOR: OK, so she was
somehow resistant to typhoid.
But then, she was cooking for
other people and, so then,
caused a bunch of infections.
Is that--?
OK.
Yeah, so this
would be an example
of a very infective
individual that's
beyond the assumptions
in this model.
And as you can imagine,
if you have variations
in this infectivity, then
what it does, for a given R0--
so if you fix R0, then you
have a broader distribution
of infectivity.
What it means is that a larger
fraction of the infections
will go extinct.
But those that get
going will be explosive.
If you're curious about
these sorts of ideas,
you should look at this
optional reading paper
that I put out there.
All right, so I just
want to be clear.
This is geometric number of
new infections, distribution
of new infections.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So is
this just one cycle?
Like, one--
PROFESSOR: So we're talking
about the number of infections
that result when you just
add one infected individual
to the population.
AUDIENCE: OK, so then, you
don't think about, afterwards,
what happens to those
infected individuals
and if they infect--
PROFESSOR: Well, we are not
yet thinking about them.
Although, in this case,
those are also geometrically
distributed.
But what you expect is that
the mean of those things
will change.
Because the number of
susceptible or whatnot
individuals-- that's
going to change.
So the mean number
is going to change.
But the distributions
will still be geometric.
AUDIENCE: But in total, that
won't be geometric anymore.
Because if we're looking
at the total number
of infected individuals after
learning about the geometric--
PROFESSOR: No.
So just because each of
these sub-steps is geometric
does not mean that you end up
with a geometric distribution.
Indeed, let's say that i put
in 20 infected individuals
into the population.
And I ask, what's going
to be the distribution
of the number of infections
caused immediately
from those 20?
That's going to be what?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Yeah, and for 20, it's going
to be basically Gaussian.
OK, well if I said 100,
well definitely Gaussian.
It's a gamma distribution
that looks very much
look a Gaussian, in that case.
All right?
All right.
So we've been talking about
the definition of this R0.
But of course, we should
figure out what it is.
We want R0 is
equal to-- and what
I'm going to tell you is that
there's a 1 over u plus v.
But then, there's
some other terms.
And I've unfortunately
lost my notes.
So you guys are going to have
to help me figure this out.
And what you're
going to do is you're
going to take advantage
of your cards.
And again, put things
in the numerators
and the denominators,
corresponding
to how I'm supposed to
fill out this equation.
You can start thinking about it
while I give you the options.
OK.
So I guess you could
recapitulate this
by just putting B and
C, although maybe you
need it more than once.
Do what you will.
Do you understand the question?
There's going to
be something else
I'm going to put right here.
And I want to know--
there are going
to be somethings in the
numerator, somethings
in the denominator.
I'm going to give you 30
seconds to think about it.
Because it's important
to be able to reason
your way through this.
All right, do need more time?
Yep, OK.
I'll give you
another 15 seconds.
All right, let's
go ahead and vote.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
All right.
I like it!
We're really looking quite nice.
So there's a claim
that it's going
to be AD over B. We should
be writing a beta k over u.
All right.
Can somebody explain
how they got there?
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: Well, it's
going to be-- these two--
PROFESSOR: OK, yeah.
This helped, right?
OK, good, perfect.
So this thing is what?
What is this term here?
AUDIENCE: That's the death rate.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Which means that the one over
it is the expected lifetime
of an infected individual.
So the definition of R0 is,
you put an infected individual
into a population
of susceptibles.
Now, we want to know,
OK, well there's
a expected lifetime of this
infected individual, which
is given by this.
And then, we have to
think about, well,
what's the rate that we're going
to be infecting individuals?
And that's going
to be beta times x.
But what we want to know is, is
x before we add any infection?
And without any infection, then
we just have a rate of entry
and, then, a death rate.
So it's just k over u.
OK?
Now, the key thing in all of
these epidemiological models
is whether this R0 is
greater or less than 1.
And that's going to tell us
whether the disease becomes
endemic or not, whether,
at steady state,
we have a population of
infected individuals.
So R0, greater than one, means
it's in an endemic population.
Now, in this model,
we can then ask--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: That really
is really funny.
AUDIENCE: That is the hard part.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So do you like A, donuts,
B, cupcakes, or C, carrots?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Yeah, it's quite nice.
Does anybody have any
notion of why somebody might
have-- so Sam likes cupcakes.
That's good to know.
Yeah, they're so pretty that I
actually feel bad erasing it.
OK, well, we'll
leave it up there --
[LAUGHTER]
--for a little bit longer.
Everybody can just
smile, because they know
that the drawing is back there.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
All right.
So in this model,
the fact that R0
is this parameter
that tells us about
whether there's going to be
an epidemic and then, indeed,
whether later the
disease will be endemic,
does that already
tell us that R0 is
what's maximized by selection?
No.
Right?
What was the key thing that
Martin does in the chapter
in order to try to understand
something about what
strain is selected for?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are you thinking of
when he introduces [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yes, although, the part of the
chapter your thinking about is,
I think, the second half.
It's talking about
super-infection,
where there's all these
different types, and craziness,
and so forth.
But the initial
insight about what
is going to be
selected for comes
from a simpler model than that.
So you don't have to think
about all those many parasites
and those triangles
and all the craziness.
Instead, there was a
simpler model that-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you have
multiple parasites,
then study states only
that one parasite exists.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
And so, what he does
is he just writes down
this model of where he now
allows two different parasites
to be spreading the population.
And at the beginning--
well, we'll write it down.
And we want to be clear.
There's a very important
assumption that he makes.
What he's going to find is
that selection maximizes R0,
the basic reproductive ratio.
And it's going to
be in this model
that I'm writing down now.
So there's this x dot.
And things look very similar.
All right.
Now, the question is,
what is the key assumption
that we're making in writing
down these equations?
Thought?
AUDIENCE: One cannot have
more than one type of--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
A host cannot be infected by
more than one type of strain.
So that's very, very important.
So there's no
super-infection, as they say.
And depending on
the disease, this
could either be a better
or worse assumption.
But then, what is it that
is defining these two
strains then?
In what ways are they different?
AUDIENCE: In virulence.
PROFESSOR: Their
virulence is different.
And what is virulence again?
AUDIENCE: How likely it
is that it could kill you.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
It's the additional
mortality that
is caused by being
affected by that strain.
Is that the only way
that they're different?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
What else is different?
AUDIENCE: The infectivity.
PROFESSOR: The
infectivity, right.
So the betas are also different.
And it's imported to
note that in this model--
it's a very simple
model-- but we're
allowing the strains to be
different in these two ways.
And I think that
it's very intuitive
to just say that, oh, well,
you want to have a larger beta,
all other things equal.
Because you would
like to spread.
But I'd say, maybe,
it's not as obvious what
happens in terms of virulence.
And then, of
course, if you think
about these two parameters--
in any biological context
they may be coupled.
In which case, things
are more subtle.
AUDIENCE: So how reasonable
is something of something
of [INAUDIBLE] on the strain?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I think that
this depends on the disease.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Is it that you're trading
virulence and new response
and--
PROFESSOR: Right, so that's
somehow the argument.
And I'd say that,
depending on whether you're
thinking about the host at the
level of an organism or a cell,
then this would correspond
to very different worlds.
So certainly, in the
context of viral infections
and individual cells, there
are various mechanisms
where, if one strain gets
in, then other strains
have trouble getting in.
Or if they do get in,
they can't do anything.
So I think, this really
depends on the biology
of the situation, whether this
is a reasonable assumption
or not.
So I'm not going to go
through all of the math.
Because it ends up being
a little bit involved.
But the condition for the mutual
invasibility of the two strains
is a little bit subtle.
So I do want to talk
about that a little bit.
And so, in general,
in this model
there's some equilibrium,
x star and y star.
And indeed, there will
generally be damped oscillations
to this equilibrium.
So this is in the model
where there's just
a single strain that's
described by some beta
and some v. Of
course, you can also
think about the equilibria, E1
and E2, that would result when
you have-- so E1 is what would
happen at the equilibrium
when you have x star evaluated
for the particular parameters
of strain one, i.e.
evaluated for beta1 and for v1.
x star-- and that's also y star.
Whereas, you would have
a different equilibrium,
E2-- so this is a x
star and a y star--
evaluated at beta2 and v2.
Do you understand
what I'm saying?
So these are the
equilibria that you
would have if this was
the only strain that
was present in the population
or if this was the only strain
in the population.
Now, it's not obvious that
those-- the equilibria--
are the result when
you have both strains
present in the population.
But that's what we want
to try to figure out.
But certainly, if you
only added strain one
and you didn't add strain 2, you
would come to equilibrium, E1.
So the question is, if we
start out at equilibrium E1,
how is it we can
determine what happens
if we now add an
infected individual,
but infected by strain two?
So what we want to know
is-- strain 2 can invade.
And really, what
we're thinking about
is a situation-- these
are the equilibria if it's
the case that R1 is greater
than 1 and R2 is greater than 1.
Because in some ways,
it's clear what happens.
If both of the R1 and R2 are
less than 1, then what happens?
AUDIENCE: It would die out.
PROFESSOR: They both die out.
If one of them is greater
than 1, one is less than 1.
Then, right, the
strain that's below 1
goes-- so the only interesting
or the only the only
non-obvious question,
somehow, is what happens
if they're both larger than 1?
What that means is
that, for example,
if you had a population of
susceptible individuals,
and you had one
infected by strain one,
one infected by
strain two, then,
in the deterministic
differential equation limit,
they would both spread.
So they're both
exponentially growing.
Does that already
tell us that you're
going to have coexistence
of the two strains?
No.
It means that they're both
exponentially spreading.
But who knows what's
going to happen later?
And indeed, what you can show
is that only one of the two
strains is going to win.
And it's the strain with the
higher reproductive ration,
the higher R0, or
in this case, here.
So how is it that we can
determine if strain two can
invade equilibrium one?
It's if-and-only-if something.
Does anybody remember what
this condition ended up being?
AUDIENCE: y2 dot at
E1 has to be positive?
PROFESSOR: All right, y2 dot
at E1 has to be positive.
Yes.
And this ends up being
equivalent, I think,
to what he writes.
So let's write.
I'll write and tell you.
So the way that he wrote
it, is that it's y2
dot, with respect to y2.
But I think that this is really
equivalent to what you said.
Because you said, OK, y2 dot
has to be something, right?
But then, y2 dot evaluated what?
And you would say,
evaluated at E1.
But then, at E1-- what is
y2 dot evaluated at E1?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: 0, right?
Because at E1, there is 0 y2.
So then, of course, y2 dot is 0.
So it's almost what you
want, but not quite.
So this condition,
which looks very weird,
is really saying that, if
we are at E1-- so there's
no infected type-two
infections-- what we want to do
is add a little bit of y2.
And then, we want to
ask, what is y2 dot?
And this derivative,
evaluated at E1,
somehow allows you to do that.
And do we want this
to be greater than 0?
Or less than 0?
We're going to do verbal answer.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: Greater.
PROFESSOR: Greater, right.
Because if it's
saying you add a y2,
you want y2 to start growing.
So you want this thing
to be greater than 0.
And this looks really crazy.
But it's actually
pretty easy to do.
Because you take the
derivative of this thing,
with respect to y2.
And you just get the thing
in parentheses, right?
But you evaluated it at E1.
So it's beta2.
And this is x star at
E1, minus u, minus v2.
And this thing has
to be greater than 0.
But this is x at E1.
That's u plus v1
divided by beta1.
So what we have is beta 2, then,
u plus v1 divided by beta1.
And this thing has to be greater
than-- we'll move this over
to the other side-- u plus v2.
OK, so this is not
so horrible, right?
There's a u plus
v1, beta1, right?
I just want to make sure I
write-- (WHISPERING) u plus v1.
(NORMAL VOICE) OK, we have
to these in the denominators
now, somehow.
So we'll put divide by
both of these things.
So we have a 1 divided
by a u plus v2.
1 divided by u plus v1.
So we put these things
in the denominator.
And now, the beta1 is
going to come up here.
So we have a beta1 and a beta2.
And there still is
a greater-than sign.
Did I screw anything up yet?
Maybe?
No?
All right.
Now, we can do
something wonderful,
which is we can just
multiply by k divided by u.
And so what does this say?
AUDIENCE: R2 is greater than R1.
PROFESSOR: R2 is
greater than R1, right?
And what were we
trying to calculate?
How did we get
started on this math?
AUDIENCE: What can
[INAUDIBLE] the strains.
PROFESSOR: Right,
we wanted to ask,
strain two can invade
the equilibrium one,
if and only if R2 is
greater than-- now,
that's interesting, right?
So that's saying
that, if you start out
with the endemic strain
one and you add the strain
two in there, it's going
to be able to invade
if it's R2 is greater than R1.
That's not obvious.
Because R2 and R1,
that was telling us
about a different situation.
That was telling us
about what happens
when you add those infected
individuals into a population
of susceptibles.
But this also ends up
telling us about what
happens when the strains are
competing against each other.
So this is so simple
that it feels trivial.
I'm sure that if you
understood it well enough,
it would be trivial.
But you'd have to think
about it more than I have.
So I think this is surprising.
Now, you can also ask
the same question,
which is about whether strain
one can invade strain two.
And that is kind
of the same thing.
So it all comes down to
the orderings of R2 and R1.
And what you find is that, if
this condition is satisfied,
strain two will drive strain
one out of the population.
AUDIENCE: What if they
strains are the same?
PROFESSOR: So if
they're the same,
then you can get coexistence.
But as Martin says,
it's non-generic,
in a sense that it's
kind of a coincidence,
or it's of measure
0, the situations
in which the two will have
the same R parameters.
But of course, you
could imagine--
just like we talked about
all this neutral evolution
business-- things
are nearly neutral
and so forth, da-da-da-- you can
kind of invoke similar ideas.
Because you can imagine that,
as these two become closer
and closer to each
other, it's going
to take longer and longer
for the more-fit strain
to out-compete the
less-fit strain.
Now, even though this is
such a simple condition
and the R parameters have
such a simple physical origin
or mathematical origin, the
actual expression for the Rs
is kind of complicated.
But again, it's a
combination of all
of these different
parameters, whether it's
the beta1, B1, or beta2, v2.
Which board do you
think is least useful?
Well, I don't want
this one anymore.
But in particular, we
want to say something
about the evolution of
virulence in this model
and what the expectation is.
So what we're going
to do is I'm going
to give you some different
situations, in terms
of how the infectivity
depends upon the virulence.
And then, you guys
will get to tell me
how the virulence will evolve.
Now, this is virulence, v. All
right, so the first situation
is if beta as a function
of the virulence-- so
the infectivity as a function
of virulence is, we'll say,
some beta0.
So first, the question is,
if the infectivity does not
depend upon the virulence,
where will virulence go to?
You have equation, various
places that'll help you.
Do you need more time?
No?
All right, ready,
three, two, one.
OK, we've got many A's.
That's great.
So if it's the case
that the parasite,
regardless of how rapidly
it's killing the individual,
has the same rate of getting
to other individuals,
then we want to make the R0
to get as large as possible.
So then, we make v go
as small as possible.
That's the mathematical
thing you can look at.
And why does this make sense?
AUDIENCE: You're
killing people off,
and you're infecting
most people.
But--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So from the standpoint
of the parasite,
in this situation where the
infectivity doesn't depend
on the virulence,
well in that case,
you don't want to
kill your host.
Because the longer
that the host lives,
the more other individuals
you can infect.
And this is the basic statement
underlying the statement
you often hear that a
well-adapted parasite does not
harm its host.
And I think this is
one of those things
that you can write
down a simple model
and convince yourself
it should be true.
You can maybe find
a few case studies
where it seems to be true.
But then, you always have to be
careful about how strongly you
should believe such
a statement based
on those kinds of evidence.
Because it's a
very simple model.
It's making an assumption
that is very likely not true
and, actually, many assumptions
that are very likely not true.
And there are counterexamples.
So Martin talks
about malaria, which
humans have had for
millions of years,
and still causes
a lot of problems.
And so you might
imagine, what would
happen if the infectivity is
a function of the virulence?
Maybe it's just proportional
to the virulence.
And this kind of
would make sense.
Because you say, oh well,
let's imagine that the number
of viruses in the host--
that somehow, the virulence
is proportional to that number.
And also, the infectivity is
proportional to that number.
In that case,
infectivity will just
scale linearly with v. It's kind
of another reasonable world.
So in this situation, where
does the virulence evolve to?
We'll think about
this for 10 seconds.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
All right, so now we
actually have votes that
are pretty distributed around.
OK, I'm just going to
write down the expression.
Just because I think
we can do it quickly.
So now, the R0 is going
to be given by-- we're
going to be thinking about a 1.
There's a u plus v down here.
But beta-- we're going
to put beta here.
This is an a times v,
and then a k over u.
Right?
So if we plot this as a function
of v, what does it look like?
AUDIENCE: It
monotonically increases.
PROFESSOR:
Monotonically increases.
This is a
Michaelis-Menten type form
where the R0 is a function
of v. It starts out
linear and, then, saturates.
Oops, this is not v. This is R0.
If we want to maximize R0,
then v goes to infinity, right?
There was one other model
that Martin talked about,
which was the situation
if the infectivity itself.
It had a kind of
Michealis-Menten type form.
And we still have an a there.
So it's some a,v c plus v. So
this would be the situation
where, initially, the
infectivity increases with
virulence.
But beyond some
virulence, you no longer
get an increase in infectivity.
So for example, if it's the
case that every time you
sneeze on somebody you're
going to infect them,
then it doesn't matter if you
double the number of viruses
you have.
You've still saturated
the infectivity.
Now, I'll just tell
you that, in this case,
there ends up being some
intermediate infectivity
that you evolve to,
which comes here.
And indeed, this makes sense.
As c goes to infinity,
so if c is very large,
then it just looks like this.
It's divided by something large.
But in terms of the scaling
with v, it's just linear in v.
And that means that the evolved
virulence goes very large.
Does that make sense?
No?
OK.
So I guess what I'm
saying is that, if you're
in the region where c is
somehow very large, then
you end up with the
infectivity just being
proportional to the virulence.
Because the virulence, the
v here in the denominator,
doesn't really
contribute very much.
And that means that it's
going to be the same kind
of functional form as this.
Except if it's a divided by c.
But it's still proportional
to the virulence.
And that leads to a larger
and larger evolved virulence.
OK?
Yep?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is it possible
to say something
in actual infection,
what the data is?
Is it virulunce?
Or can you [INAUDIBLE]--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --other than
just these verbal--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right.
So I think, from real data, I
think people do argue about it.
But I think it seems to be
there is some sense that it
does plateau.
But it's an increasing
function of v, but sub-linear.
And the question is how
strong of a statement
you can make there.
Because also, in many cases,
there is super-infection.
And super-infection tends to
lead to even higher virulence
than what you would
expect from this.
Because you're competing against
viruses in the same host.
So you have to out-compete the
other parasite in the host,
as well as go on.
And you don't pay the
full cost associated
with keeping the host alive.
So when you have
super-infection,
there's this notion that
the better strategy,
from the standpoint
of the parasite,
can be to just evolve
very high virulence.
So you're going
to kill the host.
But you can get out quickly.
So then, you can imagine
that the less-virulent strain
was kind of stranded
in that host that died.
So from that standpoint,
you can think about,
in some cases, for
a parasite, evolving
low-virulence is somehow like
some cooperative behavior.
Because you're keeping
this host alive.
You're using the
resources in a wise way,
so that you can infect
other individuals.
But then, that
kind of strategy is
susceptible to these
cheating strategies that
just have high virulence
and kill the host
and, then, get on to a new host.
Yeah, so I think there
are enough of these issues
that it's hard to take
any of this too seriously.
I would say that,
perhaps, where this field
has had the biggest impact is
in the context of vaccinations.
Because you can really measure
R0 for many different diseases.
And I think that's
somehow easier
to measure than
many other things.
Because you can try to
do tracing of infections.
So if you think about
somebody that gets infected
and moves to a new city
or lands in a new city,
you can try to figure
out who they infected.
So then, you can go and
measure these R0 parameters.
And of course, the diseases
that we worry about
tend to have R0s larger than 1.
And how large they are tells
you about how difficult
the vaccination will be
in order to be successful
and to remove the disease
from the population.
So if you're curious, after
class, you can come up.
And there's a nice
table that I have here
for smallpox, measles,
whooping cough, German measles,
chickenpox, diphtheria,
scarlet fever, mumps,
and poliomielitis.
Estimates of R0s-- and
they kind of range 5 to 15,
to give you a sense.
And so, if you want
to remove the disease
from the population,
what is it that changes?
--in terms of vaccination, in
order to remove the disease.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In R0, then,
the [INAUDIBLE] for u,
as the population
available [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So by vaccinating
you're removing
susceptible individuals
from the population
and making them
resistant somehow.
And the R0 parameter tells
you about what fraction
of the population you
have to vaccinate in order
to remove the parasite
from the population.
And so, basically,
you have to vaccinate
a fraction, a percentage, p
that's greater than 1 minus 1
over R0.
So as R0 gets very
large, it means
that you have to vaccinate,
essentially, everybody.
So if you have R0
of, say, five--
which is typical of
many of these diseases--
it's saying you
have to vaccinate
80% of the population.
You can never get to 100%.
And that's why
it's very difficult
to get rid of these
diseases with large R0s.
And incidentally, they note that
smallpox has an R0 of 3 to 5.
And this always depends
on the environment.
But in the case
where they measured,
smallpox R0 is 3 to 5.
And this is sort of
small, as compared
to many of these diseases.
And this is telling us
that smallpox is easier
to get rid of via
vaccinations than many
of these other diseases.
And indeed, the
vaccination procedures
have been more successful
in smallpox than the others.
AUDIENCE: Do you
know what is 3, 4?
PROFESSOR: I don't.
But maybe in the
next 20 minutes,
somebody can Google this.
We can estimate this
right now, though.
We've had, what?
--five Ebola patients
come to the United States.
And we've gotten two
or three infections.
So I'll say, 3/5.
[LAUGHTER]
It obviously depends on
the environment, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I mean, I guess
that was my question.
You're not going to
take someone with Ebola
and throw them in New York
City and just measure how
many people they infect.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
AUDIENCE: So--
AUDIENCE: That would
be [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Like--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but
the thing is, you
don't have to do anything
that's so immoral.
Because what you're
interested in
is the R0 for individual
in an actual environment
that they're actually
going to be in.
So this is a situation where the
doctor comes back from Africa
after working with
Doctors Without Borders.
In this day and age, he knows
that he has to watch out
for a fever, da-da-da.
And then, if he gets
a fever, he calls in.
And he's brought
to the hospital.
And that's the world that
we're interested in of what
the R0 is.
It's not the world in which
there's fevers everywhere
and nobody knows.
So the R0 in the
United States is
going to be much lower
than the R0 somewhere else.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is there enough
of R0 for a disease that you
don't transmit between people?
You get malaria of the plague--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right.
So I think that you could try
to generate a similar kind of R0
for those to diseases.
Although, it's going
to be very muddled,
in the case of where you have
all the vectors and so forth.
Because it's not
even clear-- yeah,
I'm hesitant to say too much.
Because I don't know anything.
AUDIENCE: According
to Wikipedia,
it's like 1.5 to 2.5.
PROFESSOR: For Ebola?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Here?
Or in--
AUDIENCE: It says the 2014
West Africa aggregate.
PROFESSOR: Ah, so this
is in West Africa then.
AUDIENCE: Apparently.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yeah And it has obviously
spread exponentially,
which means it had to
have been larger than 1.
And I think it's important to
remember that, just because you
have a chart with a bunch of
R0s, this is not set in stone.
Public policy, hygiene, and
everything changes this.
And we'd like to drive it down.
Was there a question
in the back?
AUDIENCE: I just was
going to say about two.
PROFESSOR: Same
thing, about two.
OK, so that means that we
could actually, in principle,
vaccinate against Ebola.
We'd only have to get over 50%
of the population vaccinated
in West Africa.
And then, we can maybe make it
so it cannot spread and become
an epidemic.
Of course, we need to
have a vaccine first.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So I think
I'm going to skip
the discussion of SIR models.
Because you are going to
play with some of them
in the context of
your problem set.
And if you just Google
SIR, you can find it.
And a very similar
kind of intuition
that you get from this model.
Because I do want to spend
the last 15 minutes, at least,
talking about the
evolution of sex.
Because it is an
interesting topic.
And I think the paper is
a nice discussion of it.
So can somebody say why it is
that this is a puzzle at all?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: In almost all
the situations we imagine
and things that can be
[INAUDIBLE] introduce much
faster, even violating
the [INAUDIBLE]--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
AUDIENCE: --80%
[INAUDIBLE] right?
PROFESSOR: So sex is costly,
and in particular, if you have
this obligate bi-parental sex.
In particular, there's
the so-called twofold cost
of males.
Because you can imagine
comparing these two
populations, one of which
has both males and females.
And one of them is just,
maybe, reproducing asexually,
or parthenogenetically,
or hermaphroditically,
or what not.
And so, if you have
a male and a female,
then on average, if
they have two kids,
you end up with another
male and a female.
And of course, this could
be many different males
and females.
So you don't have to have
any sibling anything.
But if, every
generation, each female
is giving birth to
two progeny, then you
end up with a constant
population size.
Whereas, if you started
out in a population
with just two females
and they were reproducing
hermaphroditically, then you
end up with-- whatever-- more.
8.
So you can see that
you get a factor of 2
in the rate of exponential
growth of the population.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, it seems to me
the question is not why sex,
but it's why males.
Right, I mean--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So I think this is the
most extreme cost of sex.
But then, also, you can
think about even just
horizontal gene-transfer
among bacteria.
It's a costly behavior
in some way or another.
It's not as costly as this.
But if you're going to
think about bacteria
in their competence state,
when B. subtilis kind of pulls
in DNA, it stops dividing.
And then, it enters a state
where it reels things in.
And it can pick up DNA that
may be harmful in some cases.
So there are various costs
for, if you want to call it,
horizontal gene-transfer sex.
So the key thing of
sexual reproduction
is it somehow is the
sharing of the DNA.
And I'd say that this can
either be relatively low cost
or relatively high cost.
But this is the most
extreme version of it.
And I'd say, as a
species that reproduces
with obligate
bi-parental sex, then
I'd say that, not only
humans, but almost all animals
have this form of reproduction.
I would say it's
sort of surprising,
given that this is a huge cost.
But it's not that
all species that
engage in any sort
of gene-transfer
bear this large of a cost.
But they bear more modest costs.
AUDIENCE: Well, although,
other species do-- even
with this [INAUDIBLE],
it's like having
multiple children per sex.
PROFESSOR: You're saying that
they can just have more kids.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I mean--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, although the
basic statement is still true.
Let's say that these
females all have three kids.
They get to grow exponentially.
But then, these
guys grow faster.
And ultimately, there's going
to be competition for resources.
And these ones will still win.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So the
question is-- you
can imagine you have
a population that's
reproducing sexually-- if one
female has a mutation that
leads her to start
reproducing parthogenetically,
that mutation you'd
expect should spread
throughout the
population very rapidly.
And indeed, there are these
cases of, for example,
sharks held in captivity
where a female held
in captivity for years
eventually gives birth
to daughters.
So this sort of virgin
birth is possible.
I'm not aware-- well, I'm
not going to talk about--
[LAUGHTER]
But in some animals, it is
at least possible, I'll say.
So then, you have
to ask, well, what
kind of selective advantage
could sexual reproduction have
that could possibly compensate
for this so-called twofold cost
of sex or twofold cost of males?
And what is the argument
that's made in this paper?
Anybody?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The recombination
favors genetic diversity.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
This recombination is
favoring genetic diversity.
So there are a number
of different mechanisms.
I'd say that at the heart of
this idea of the Red Queen
hypothesis is-- let
me see if I can find
the actual quote for you guys.
Maybe not.
So it's from a
Lewis Carroll novel,
Through the Looking Glass.
The quote was something--
run-- oh, shoot.
Never mind, I can't
remember what the quote was.
But the idea is that
sexual reproduction
may allow a population
to adapt against, say,
changing environments
more rapidly.
And this has a
couple of reasons.
Because you generate
genetic diversity.
You don't have the same
clonal interference effects
that we talked about earlier.
So if you have asexual
lineages, then,
if you have two
beneficial mutations,
they cannot both fix.
So the more fit version
is going to fix.
And then, you have to
wait for the next one.
Whereas, in sexually
reproducing populations,
those genes can spread
throughout the population,
sort of as genes,
rather than being tied
to a particular individual.
So that means that, if you find
yourself in a new environment,
it may be the case that
sexual reproduction can
allow for the population
to adapt more rapidly.
But on one hand, you might say,
well, the environment's always
changing.
So that can always favor
the sexually reproducing
populations.
But then, there's
a feeling out there
that maybe that's not
enough, in the sense
that the environment
is not changing
rapidly enough and
dramatically enough
to force the population to
reproduce sexually as compared
to asexually.
And so, the proposal from
the Red Queen Hypothesis
is that the constantly
changing environment
is a result of
co-evolution between hosts
and their parasites.
Because parasites are always
trying to target common host
genotypes.
Because they can
spread on those.
So the parasites are evolving.
And then, the host
populations or genotypes
are kind of being chased
away by those parasites that
are targeting them.
So the notion is that
parasites, as a result
of this co-evolution, can be
the source for the constantly
changing environment that may
be driving the evolution of sex.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: And this, proportional
with [INAUDIBLE], bacteria
also get parasites [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
AUDIENCE: So--
PROFESSOR: Yes, so is
the question is why--
AUDIENCE: Why only in multi--
PROFESSOR: Right.
So I can give you my
best guess on this.
First of all, not everybody
agrees that the Red Queen
Hypothesis is the
true explanation,
if a true explanation
even exists.
But within this
framework, you definitely
want to try to explain why it
is that large life forms seem
to have a lot of obligate
sexual reproduction.
Because this is a very
strong pattern that you see.
And I guess what I would say
is that there's certainly
a correlation between physical
size and generation time.
And generation time
tells you something
about the typical time scales
over which you can evolve.
So my sense of this
is it just maybe
that, in general, large
animals, by their nature,
will evolve rather slowly as
compared to their parasites.
And so, that means that they
are the populations that
are most in need of
speeding up their evolution.
And it's hard to know how
convincing that argument
should be.
But-- yes?
AUDIENCE: What's the difference
in reproductive productive time
between phage and bacteria?
Like, how fast does phage--
PROFESSOR: Right.
So bacteria can--
as we've discussed,
division times are order hour.
And phage-- when you get a
phage infection, what happens
is that the phage you can
infect as a single phage.
And then, they will divide
within the bacterial cell
and then burst out as
a population of 100,
200-- typical of phage.
And I think that that
might take four or five
hours, is kind of my sense.
And then, they go off and
they find new bacteria.
So in that sense, it's a little
bit faster than the bacteria,
I'd say.
So can somebody say what the
core experiment was that they
did in this experiment?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
and one time,
it was reproducing
asexually when they always
produce sexually.
And the other time,
it was dividing.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So this worm, C. Elegans--
sort of a millimeter in size--
and there are going to be
three different conditions.
One is the wild type that can
out-cross, can have males mate.
Then, there's the
obligate out-crossing,
which means they have
to mate with males.
And then, there's the--
what did they call it?
--obligate selfing.
OK.
And then, what they
do with those worms?
AUDIENCE: They put
them right back
to [INAUDIBLE] more typical.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So then, there's a bacterial
pathogen, Serratia marcescens.
And they're going to have these
three different conditions.
For the SM, the
bacteria, they're
either going to allow
for co-evolution, where
they take the bacteria
from each of the infections
and propagate.
Or they're going to do the
no evolution, where you just
compete against the ancestor.
And there's also a control.
So there's co-evolution.
There's this no evolution
of the bacteria.
And then, there's also control,
where there's no bacteria.
And what was the
most striking thing
that they saw in
this experiment?
AUDIENCE: I guess I would
say that the obligate-selfing
population died in evolution.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So if you allowed the
bacteria to be evolving,
against this obligately
selfing population,
this killed the worms.
And what was the
other thing that
was, maybe, very striking
about their experiment?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The worms that did
the out-cross or self increased.
[INAUDIBLE]--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so this
was kind of amazing.
So they saw, as a
function of time,
if you look at out-crossing--
the rate of mating
with the males-- this
started out at, like, 0.2.
And then, in the presence of
the co-evolution, it went up.
And it goes up to, maybe, 80%.
And for co-evolution,
it stayed up high.
Whereas, if the
wild-type worms continued
to be just challenged by
the ancestral bacteria,
it initially came up.
But then, it came back down.
So this is the co-evolution.
And this is the ancestral SM.
So there was a sense that
that wild-type population
had initially evolved
to out-cross more.
But then, once it had
solved this problem of how
to handle the
ancestral Serratia,
the out-crossing
rate went back down.
So we are pretty
much out of time.
But I don't know
if you guys noticed
the last sentence of the paper.
It is amazing that they got
this through the publication
process.
All right, so they
say, "taken together,
the results demonstrate that
sex can facilitate adaptation
to novel environments.
But the long-term
maintenance of sex
requires that the novelty
does not wear off."
[LAUGHTER]
It's one of those things that
you read and you think-- OK.
So I will leave that
sentence with you.
And then, we'll
meet on Tuesday, OK?